c'est parce que tu crois c'est une
copine et c'est pas rien point le plus
bas reste on s'est rencontrés moi je les
connaissais de nom j'avais vu leur leurs
affiches à château rouge mais si tiens
qu'est ce que c'est que ces deux
loustics
et puis on s'est rencontré en fait à
omagh 36 lors d'un spectacle des bodin's
un des derniers spectacles des menaces
de retour au pays où on s'est rencontré
à la fin du spectacle on a sympathisé
puis voilà la rencontre s'est fait comme
ça et on l'a notre collaboration a
commencé ici en fait
voilà
ils ont déjà il crée un premier
spectacle il avait envie de poursuivre
l'aventuré leur soin de mettre de
remettre en selle retravaillé premier
spectacle ou dans à m'écrire un nouveau
les parties sur cette option là où ils
ont fait un beau travail d'écriture et
puis on a vraiment phare créé ce
spectacle du début à la fin ils ont
écrit tous les textes et puis moi je
m'occupe de la mise en scène et on c'est
un régal de travailler avec eux tu sais
le week end
oui c'est alors moi oui et j'y mets mais
balance déjà julien g tech auto menti
parce que quand tu vois tout passage
quand tu vois ses doigts du mans ce soir
messages et lettres en première ronde
ici pour prendre en charge ce qui m'a
dit tu vois tu fais toujours prendre
quand tu vois tous ces mecs quand tu
vois que tu as tous ces mecs déjà en
couple et que ça revient avec un numéro
en poche chez eux hier encore j'ai pas
mes doigts par exemple tu dirais quoi
mais je dirais que tu pu aller acheter
le mensonge c'est vrai qu'ils sont à
dida qui s'en cache pas mais justement
il faut s'en servir comme d'une force
parce que quelquefois on est on peut
être déformée par des cours de théâtre
des choses comme ça ils sont tous tout
neuf
voilà et ils sont ils sont pleins
d'entrain ils ont une écriture qui était
qu'ils ont vraiment un style à eux qui
est un peu un peu un peu trash quelques
fois mais justement c'est ce qu'il faut
conserver
et puis
et puis j'aime beaucoup faire travailler
les actes en fallait des dirigé trouver
les intentions et c'est donc ce c'est un
petit peu ce qui leur manquait aussi
aussi d'un petit peu de rigueur dans
dans le dans certaines scènes et c'est
donc tout ça on est en train de
l'apprendre il travaillait en même temps
mais c'est toujours passionnant nous
apporte quelque chose qui est
extraordinaire enfin s'en rend compte
aujourd'hui des choses qu'on néglige et
enfin c'est un travail est ok super
intéressant et nous apporte énormément
tout ce qui se passe là avec jean
christian avec la nouveauté la façon de
travailler qui est qui est un milieu de
ce qu'on avait fait avec le nouveau
super avec le premier spectacle quand
même enfin mais c'est super quoi ces
mêmes dans le détail jusqu'à jusqu'à
regarder dans les coulisses où sera le
costume s'il est bien ouvert et tout
alors que nous mettez tout en boule
comme ça on arrivait dans les coulisses
ont changé comment on pouvait alors que
là non du coup tout est chronométré en
chronomètre pendant lé répète et sa faim
voilà c'est génial quoi ça fait partie
du jeu je finirai par savoir de toute
façon je peux tout savoir mais plutôt
merapi hier la chaud comme tout
bon ton prénom même à rien mais non mais
pas tu as l'air leuthard rencontre
sophie généralement on a plus souvent la
plus d'appréhension dans les petites
salles que dans un que même dans un
zénith parce qu un zénith c'est bon
c'est sympa mais c'est très c'est un peu
plus impersonnel le public on a moins de
réaction directe avec ce que là on voit
la personne du premier rang et du
dernier rang d'ailleurs du balcon donc
c'est vrai qu'il sait c'est dans les
petites vacances et c'est vraiment une
loupe on a vraiment les yeux sur le sur
les comédiens on rate rien des comédiens
donc ski
et le jeu du comédien peut s'apparenter
ici à un jeu devant la caméra justement
où la caméra vient chercher le le jeu de
l'acteur est là c'est un peu ça donc on
travaille tout en finesse et cetera on
décortique tous les dialogues et on
essaie de mettre en avant tout ça quoi
au